if you're looking for ways to use your
time well enhance your good habits and
get consumed by positivity then this
video is for you
in the new year to come invest in taking
care of your body
invest in nurturing and nourishing your
relationships focus on the good things
that are happening in your life and to
focus on the good things and be grateful
doesn't happen automatically when it
comes to good habits in the year 2018
let us consciously enhance them lead
motivation watch a top 10 with believe
nation what's up it's Evan my 1 word is
believe and I believe in you I believe
you have an amazing gift inside you that
I want to see explode out into the world
so let's get your motivation to attend
and get you believing in you grab a
snack and chew on today's lessons from a
man who went from working as an
electrical engineer from hewlett-packard
to becoming a monk and life coach
teaching people the importance of coping
with stress happiness and conscious
leadership he's got work appalled ass
and here's my take on his top ten roses
success vol 2 enjoy
rule number one utilize your time well
there are four things that we can never
recover in our life a stone after it has
been thrown into the valley words after
they have been spoken an opportunity
once it is missed and time once it has
gone considering the average lifespan of
a human being today to be about 70 years
seventeen multiplied by 12 is 840 now
that's how many months we have in our
life to live in this world and if life
is represented by a jar and those 840
months by the marbles in the jar every
year 12 marbles are being thrown out of
the charm last year 12 marbles have gone
as well gone forever never to come back
again
look at how many marbles we now have in
the jar to make a difference to leave a
mark to stand apart
utilize your time well and your time
will treat you well leading you into an
overall sense of well-being in the new
year to come
invest in taking care of your body
invest in nurturing and nourishing your
relationships invest in finding and
discovering your purpose your passion
your calling in order to enhance your
professional growth invest in pursuing
and cultivating a meaningful deep
spiritually connect and for some reason
if you found yourself stuck in any of
these some of these or all of these
areas in the last year
the new year brings a fresh opportunity
to press the refresh button refresh the
page of your life and live well because
at the end of the day remember we are
all just stories
and make sure
is inspiring rule number two focus that
one looks at the cream standing on one
leg completely focused into the waters
the crane with one pointed attention is
looking at the waters as the fishes are
swimming inside the water the crane will
allow the tiny the small fish to swim
around and not be satisfied with them
it'll allow the fishes the small fishes
to go around and swim around the crane
will focus and wait for the big fish to
come if the qurían settles with the
small fish it'll lose the big fish and
the crane wants the big fish it has to
allow the small fish to pass by and go
around
similarly in life when you want to focus
on what is important we should allow the
small things to pass by we shouldn't be
distracted by the little things
sometimes they'll be interpersonal
issues and conflicts sometimes there'll
be some health crises sometimes there
might be a financial crisis so many
things keep happening in life let the
small things pass by and focus on what's
important rule number three act with a
vision Thomas Alva Edison once made a
very nice statement he said genius is 1%
inspiration and 99% perspiration
we may have an inspiration in our heart
but 1% strong burning Inferno of an
inspiration but unless that inspiration
is put into action dedicated committed
hard work that 99% perspiration we are
not going to be able to achieve what we
want to achieve and so also when we talk
about dealing with our bad habits
success is 1% inspiration and 99%
perspiration
we need that inspiration but based on
the foundation of that inspiration we
have to put an
dedicated committed hard work that 99%
perspiration what's amazing is that 99%
perspiration is based on the foundation
of that 1% inspiration if the foundation
of a building is in place the very first
thing that we make when it comes to
building a structure a house a beautiful
edifice or a mansion is we put the
foundation in place if the foundation is
in place if it's strong and robust then
all the building block is the bricks the
cement the mortar the steel can go on
and form a beautiful structure for us to
live in for us to dwell in and so also
that 1% inspiration is the foundation of
that 99% perspiration imagine if you're
very inspired to change if you're very
inspired to give up some of your bad
habits but you don't put that hard work
that 99% perspiration what good is that
inspiration or imagine if you keep
putting 99% of perspiration that hard
work that effort the dedicated
commitment but if you don't have that
inspiration to do it in the right
direction and sustain it and get it a
higher shelf life what good is that hard
work and perspiration
therefore success comes by a balance of
the two inspiration which acts as the
foundation and perspiration which acts
as the building blocks to build upon
that foundation I once read a very
interesting Japanese proverb it said
action without vision is a nightmare
if you simply keep acting without having
the right vision the result is a
nightmare and it said vision without
action is a daydream if you simply have
a vision and you don't act upon it all
you have as a result is a daydream
I have rephrased it for our discussion
here today perspiration
without inspiration is a nightmare but
inspiration without perspiration is a
daydream rule number four get consumed
by productivity it consumed by the
positive energy focus not on your bad
habits get consumed not by the negative
energy of your bad habit sometimes we
just get so consumed by that all that's
playing on our mind is that no that's
meant to be dealt with focus on the good
things that are happening in your life
and to focus on the good things and be
grateful doesn't happen automatically
it's not our default setting our default
setting is to go towards the negative
our default setting is it to focus on
the negative we have to customize our
lives by being consciously aware we have
to become more mindful and conscious of
the wonderful gifts the wonderful
opportunities the wonderful blessings
that we've been showered with and with
that positive energy but bad positive
emotion of gratitude feel tremendously
empowered to deal with our bad habits to
deal with our challenges and therefore
do not be hateful about what you are
going through in life be grateful for
all those wonderful gifts that have been
given in your life rule number five take
on challenges I feel challenges are such
an integral part of growth in our life
for example a teacher will always pose
higher and higher challenges to the
students why because the teacher wants
the student to grow in his or her
understanding of the subject mathematics
for instance what's mathematics in
kindergarten and primary school in
secondary school in university is
different why because the challenge
level goes on increasing and the higher
the challenge and
in a better way we are able to crack it
we simply grow deeper in our
understanding of the subject there is no
meaning to life without a challenge and
the symptom of greatness is to accept
that challenge in a very sportive spirit
and learn how to grow deeper in whatever
we are doing rule number six rewrite
your mistakes when you write you will
most certainly end up making mistakes
what's truly great is that right behind
you is attached an eraser and you can
actually correct that mistake
and once again write the right thing
ladies and gentlemen even in our lives
we make so many mistakes and what's
amazing is God has given us the
opportunity the chance to erase them to
correct them and to rewrite our stories
we all make mistakes I remember I once
went for a program and a gentleman came
to me and said Prabhu gee I'm your fan I
said why he said your talks are really
inspiring especially the jokes I said
what about the points man he said the
points are good but the jokes are great
I said to him come on all the jokes are
only meant to really pass on the message
and drive home the point and just as we
were talking a little boy came running
and I said your son right he said yeah
and just following the boy came a lady I
said your daughter right and the man
turned blue and the lady was like all
smiles a year two years smile because
she was not as daughter she was actually
his wife the guy turned to his wife and
said Prabhu Chico's either seriously
Neil inika good jokes Monica Botha that
day
oh my god I realized God had made a big
mistake there by asking if it was his
daughter when she was actually his wife
we all make mistakes now anyone who
comes to me with people around I never
ask whether this is your son or daughter
or wife of father or mother I just ask
can you kindly introduce me to everyone
please simple isn't it yes we make
mistakes we should learn from those
mistakes I raise them correct them
and never repeat them rule number seven
win the war now the nature of success is
that it gets into our heads and makes us
complacent for the first guys if you've
been successful in keeping up with your
commitment
don't let it get into your head don't
get proud don't get complacent because
complacency will stop your growth and
the nature of failure is whenever we are
not able to keep up with our commitments
whenever we are not able to do what we
want to do is that it gets into a heart
and makes us depressed ladies and
gentlemen if in the last week you
haven't been able to keep up with your
commitments don't worry don't get
depressed don't feel guilty that guilt
if it helps you to improve is good but
that guilt if it just sends you into
into sends you into a mental trap that
guilt is no good in fact I always say
this it's not about losing a particular
battle it's about winning the war
ladies and gentlemen every war is made
of many small and tiny battles and it's
only utopia of fantasy and imagination
to think that those who are fighting in
the war will win every battle that is
impossible
even during the Kurukshetra war when the
five brothers the pandavas the noble
ones were fighting with the hundred
cousins the vicious ones the Kauravas
the whole idea was about winning the war
and the Pandavas kept losing many
battles during the war a Beeman emergen
son was killed her tooth catch beam the
son was killed the five sons of draupadi
were killed so many losses during that
war it's not that the pandavas won every
battle but they were certainly
victorious in the war and during those
battles when they lost those battles
it's natural that we feel depressed it's
natural that we kind of have the
tendency to give up this is when lord
krishna came
to the rescue by always bringing their
attention to the final goal to keep
their eyes focused on the final goal of
winning the war rule number eight
enhance your good habits I really want
all of you to truly truly introspect if
you decided something in the last year
2017 and did you truly work on it
through the year and where do you stand
today throughout the day today till we
meet the next morning tomorrow at eight
o'clock I want all of you to introspect
this one-word introspection to see if
you've actually worked on what you
decided or were you a victim of
resolution dissolution and no solution
ladies and gentlemen I often say with
habits are of three kinds the first is
our good habits and when we talk about
good habits for example saying a thank
you this is an example or saying a sorry
being hospitable courteous kind is a
good habit and very often it's just a
habit though very often we could say a
thank you or even say you're sorry and
not even mean it we go into the
autopilot mode and that's why we call it
a habit it's just in the autopilot mode
we say thank you we don't mean it we may
say oh sorry we may not mean it and
therefore when it comes to good habits
in the year 2018 let us consciously
enhance them not just sustain and
enhance those habits but consciously
enhance those habits which is basically
for example we see say a thank you we
mean thank you excel for example if we
say oh sorry we mean as sorry as well
they're good habits and you could
identify your own good habits and make
sure that we do not continue them in an
autopilot mode in the year 2018 so with
the
good habits we don't want to be in the
autopilot mode but you want to
consciously enhance the quality of those
good habits as we enter the year 2018
rule number nine go through the pain
unless you go through sharpening what is
within you will not come out the pencil
has to go through painful sharpening
before the sharp blade comes out and
makes an impact ladies and gentlemen
similarly in life unless we go through
painful sharpening the best things
within will never come out as they say
no pains no gains rule number ten do the
right things many of you have many of
you some of you have commented and asked
me this question that all this sounds
easier than done it's easy to say these
things easy to listen to these things
when it comes to practical
implementation application and dealing
with these things in real life it seems
very difficult it seems very hard but
that's very true what you've said is
perfectly true because only the wrong
things come very easy the right things
that we need to do in our life don't
come that easily you know when we do the
wrong things they give us that momentary
pleasure and they're extremely easy to
do although they give us that momentary
pleasure and they're easy to do in the
long run however we have to pay a very
high price in terms of our physical
emotional mental and spiritual
well-being although they give us
pleasure and they are easy god they
really caused a lot of trouble later on
the other hand the right things they
cause pain in the beginning they're
painful to do a lot of hard work
they don't come easy and
we just are willing to bear that initial
pain that initial hard work that initial
discomfort and that initial could be a
long time actually in the long run these
right things these right habits pay back
a massive premium to us in terms of
sustained pleasure safe pleasure which
has a very high shelf value and it is
not at all destructive to our overall
sense of well-being this kind of
pleasure coming from the right things
lord krishna calls these pleasures in
the bhagavad-gita as sattvic pleasures
of pleasures in the mode of goodness
they cause pain in the beginning
discomfort in the beginning but they pay
back a huge premium in terms of
sustained high shelf pleasures on the
other hand lord krishna calls this
short-term pleasures come that come by
doing wrong as pleasures in the mode of
ignorance or Tomczyk pleasures these
pleasures are momentarily very exciting
thrilling exhilarating and they easy to
go but in the long run we have to pay a
huge price therefore ladies and
gentlemen do not worry so much about
what is easy or hard worry about what is
right and wrong the right things may be
hard but we should be doing it in a
long-term interest the wrong things may
come easy but we should be avoiding them
in our long-term interest therefore even
if being polite sensitives we're
sportive kind to others may be hard even
of putting all these things that we've
spoken in the last couple of days into
practice beasts sounds very hard and
difficult but that's the right thing to
do ladies and gentlemen in our
transformative journey we have to worry
about the right thing to do not the easy
thing to do and right things require a
lot of hard work but bit by bit as we
work hard we can get there so I had
honestly never heard of him before we
did the top ten was a success volume one
on
and I'm so glad we're able to do a
volume two because he brings so much
wisdom and just the way he tells the
stories really connects with me
whether it's the crane or the marbles or
the pencils he has a way to find what
seems to be ordinary life or an ordinary
object and bring it meaning and bring it
value and so I really appreciate his
perspective I think rule number one is
probably my personal favorite just that
idea of not living with regrets making
today count not let another 12 months go
by another 12 marbles and to your jar
before you take action on that thing
that you want to do and bringing it down
to the every day like today matters this
moment matters don't put off your dream
until tomorrow say I'm gonna make that
phone call next week it's so easy to
just feel like we have infinite time but
we don't and so I want this video that
I'm making right now to matter and then
the next one I'm gonna make right after
I don't want that to matter to if think
if you make work every single day that
your grandkids would want to see make
work that you are so proud of every day
that you want to show your grandkids if
you did that every day your life would
be unrecognizable it just would be you
fast forward a year five years ten years
you'll be a totally different human
being and so making that your goal to
make work every single day that you want
to show your grandkids I think is a
noble one and so rule number one is my
personal favorite I love to know from
you guys though what was your personal
favorite did you do you agree with me is
rule number one the best rule or is
there one that you like better leave it
down the comments below I'm really
curious to see what you have to say
now I made this video because you'll
guess desai asked me to if there's
something you'd like me to a future top
10 video on check out the link in the
description and you can go and cast your
vote I also want to give a quick shout
out to Helen Ashcroft from stronghold
media Helen thank you so much for
picking up a copy of my new book the top
ten roses success I'm so glad you
enjoyed it thank you for taking that
picture and all your support on the book
so thank you guys again for watching I
believe in you I hope you continue to
believe in yourself and whatever your
one where it is
much love I'll see you soon
all of us in our childhood read the
story of a crew who was extremely
thirsty and was flying around looking
for some water the crew found a pitcher
of water as the crew landed itself on
the rim of the pitcher and looked inside
at the contents he found there was water
but the water was at the very bottom of
the pitcher and there was no way that
the crew could drink water by putting
its beak inside the crew started
thinking what should be done and it came
across a brilliant idea
it started flying around and picking up
in its beak tiny pebbles and putting
them inside the pitcher pebble by pebble
by pebble the crew kept working hard
until the level of the water rose way up
to the rim of the pitcher and the crew
quenched its thirst Kaka Ashta refers to
the patient hard work and the effort of
the crew yes ladies and gentlemen if we
have to work on our lives if we have to
truly bring what is within outside we
have to go through some painful
sharpening of Kaka chasta hard work and
don't they say that the only place where
success comes before work is in the
dictionary
that's because s comes before W long
the most important work ever if you had
to think of one word that's most
important to you or that sums you Apple
that would be to like a little beacon
they believe nation if you want to know
what the most important one word is for
Tony Robbins Gary Vaynerchuk Oprah
Winfrey will.i.am and Howard Schultz I
have a very special secret video for you
check the description for details